innanzitutto vorrei dirvi come sono
arrivato qui su questo palcoscenico
direi che tutto iniziò un giorno di
tanti anni fa quando mi accorsi di aver
finito tutti i libri da leggere
era un ragazzino amavo molto la lettura
leggevo qualunque cosa così quel mattino
d'agosto andando alla spiaggia mi ferma
in edicola dvd esposto un volumetto
della nuova serie questo volumetto di un
animaletto fantascienza ma mi curiosi
anche perché era bello spesso di 700
lire mi sembrava un ottimo affare dico
che per una settimana sono tranquillo
arriva la spiaggia sotto l'ombrellone
iniziai a leggere e non smisi finché non
arrivare all'ultima pagina alle 2 di
notte
quindi possiamo dire questo libro
ovviamente ha cambiato la mia vita
perché da quel momento ho letto tutta la
fantascienza che potevo e ho iniziato ad
immaginare tutti i possibili futuri che
mi stavano nella mia mente forse per
quello che sono diventato un ricercatore
e forse per quello che sei diventato un
robotico e questa sera mi piacerebbe
accompagnarvi in un viaggio alla
scoperta del futuro della robotica dove
comincia questo viaggio direi comincia
qui da questa sala
in questo momento alzi la mano chi non
ha uno smartphone in tasca
nessuno tutti avete uno smartphone e non
usate solo per telefonare ovviamente lo
usate per comunicare con le chat per far
fotografie per guardare che tempo fa e
scaricate le app ormai l'app store di
apple
il google play store vi sono più
familiari della coop e di esselunga
questo significa che a parte qui dove
c'è una gabbia di faraday per proteggere
gli speaker dal dal chattare continuo si
via internet da per tutta la rete con
voi siete sempre collegati 3g 4g e wifi
bluetooth significa che internet è
diventato un bisogno primario tant'è
vero che l'onu lo ha dichiarato tra i
diritti fondamentali e che la camera da
poco tempo ha approvato una mozione per
una carta dei diritti di internet
e allora questo il punto di partenza non
solo i telefonini ormai sono collegati a
internet ma tutto tutte le cose senza
internet of things sono collegate a
internet perché sono tutti apparecchi
tutti apparecchi controllati da
microprocessori calcolatori che tramite
la rete possono scaricare gli
aggiornamenti software ma possono anche
essere telecontrollati voi potete
chiaramente accendere il condizionatore
prima ad arrivare a casa per trovarla a
casa fresca e quindi questa è una volta
si chiamava domotica ma ormai con la
rete è superato perché la rete
dappertutto nei più solo a casa e
nell'ufficio e sull'autobus l'avete in
tasca la rete quindi è diventato appunto
questo cloud questa nuvola che vi
avvolge e avvolge e non è più soltanto
una nuvola a cui accedere con uno
schermo con una tastiera è una nuvola
che però ha delle pro pagina delle mani
degli occhi delle
delle orecchie e quindi qualunque cosa è
collegata di internet tra attenzione non
solo le cose normali come frigorifero il
condizionatore sono collegati ad
internet ma per le case cominciano a
girare anche oggetti come questo vedete
questo si chiama rumba è stato il primo
prodotto venduto in dieci milioni di
esemplari
e questo è l'ultimo esemplare è dotato
di programmi di controllo molto molto
avanzati praticamente a di praticamente
lì senza artificiale che tramite i
sensori e telecamere mappano la stanza
impara nel vostro ambiente decidono in
modo autonomo il percorso per pulire
l'ambiente quando non hanno più energia
si vanno a ricaricare da soli per sono
ovviamente collegati ad internet e voi
potete sapere cosa sta succedendo
ecco quindi che tutto ciò che c'è in
giro sta diventando un robot quindi non
è più internet of things diventerà
internet offre robot ma i robot direte
voi non erano quelle macchine grosse
rumorose che stavano nelle fabbriche per
costruire le autovetture saldare
verniciare sì senz'altro da 60 anni
questi sono i robot ma dopo 60 anni di
successi
questa ormai è lo standard nelle
fabbriche non è più una novità ormai è
normalissimo sostituire l'uomo in tutti
i lavori faticosi pesanti ripetitivi e
eventualmente che richiedono alta
precisione però quello che sta
succedendo è che stanno uscendo dalle
fabbriche non sono più segregati nelle
loro gabbie per non aver contatti sta
diventando il robot di servizi quindi
possono essere ruspe possono essere
gru possono essere autovetture senza
pilota
oppure come in questo caso umanoidi cioè
bipedi meccanici dotati di due braccia
due gambe una testa che sono sicuramente
i più affascinanti perché ci ricordano
la nostra forma fisica e sono anche
quelli che stimolano maggiormente la
nostra fantasia però non vanno solo nei
boschi evidentemente questo genere di
robot sarà il più adatto a essere
inserito in ambienti umani non è che sia
importantissima la forma bipede umanoide
lo è nel momento i cui deve condividere
lo spazio con esseri umani che sono
abituati a essere affiancati da essere
umani allora può essere più facile avere
un assistente robotico fatta forma più o
meno di essere umano che non assistente
robotico fatta forma per esempio di di
aspirapolvere e quindi saranno
assistenti nostre case ovviamente
collegati ad internet e tramite questo
potranno fare molto più di quello che è
il loro aspetto esteriore perché
potranno sì per esempio un robot
assistente per una persona anziana che
vive sola in casa potrà monitorarne lo
stato di salute aiutarlo a svolgere
funzioni fisiologiche se questa persona
oa qualche impedimento fisico potrà
tenere un collegamento continuo quel
centro di controllo quindi farò persone
di telemedicina però potrà fare anche
compagnia giocare con questa persona
anziana a fargli riabilitazione fisica
psichica a diventare un hub di
comunicazione con altre persone come lui
che condividano questa condizione o con
la famiglia
ecco quindi che diventano macchine
potentissime macchine che hanno un
potenziale enorme di miglioramento della
nostra vita
per esempio nella società che sta
invecchiando il problema degli anziani
soli e molto forti infatti in giappone
che è la società più diciamo col maggior
tasso di invecchiamento stanno
investendo moltissimo nel robot
companion
però stiamo parlando di questi compagni
d'avventura nelle nostre case i nostri
uffici che possono avere tante forme che
vedete una patologia di esempi presi
dall handbook of robotics appena uscito
è l'enciclopedia mondiale della robotica
però presentano anche la possibiltà
potenziali problematiche tipo etico
legale sociale perché sono macchine
progettate per assisterci quindi avranno
una doppia funzione da un lato dovranno
osservarci capire come funzionano capire
nostro linguaggio e il nostro body
language le nostre gestualità e di baila
lui deve capire cosa sta dicendo noi sta
dando alla coordinata xy e quindi
dovranno apprendere progressivamente
vivendo insieme a noi come servirci
meglio e quindi fare un'operazione
profiling di creazione di un modello del
nostro comportamento molto più raffinato
di quello che può fare google guardando
i siti che navighiamo gli oggetti che
comperiamo e tutti questi dati però
saranno da qualche parte nella tessera
computer no saranno sicuramente in cloud
grande backup gli algoritmi stessi
tutto questo chiaramente crea delle
problematiche di sicurezza problematiche
perché è facile fare degli stand di
sicurezza per una lavatrice per evitare
che uno si possa far male ma se stiamo
parlando di macchine intelligenti dotate
di capacità di apprendimento di
autonomia decisionale è difficile essere
sicuri che dopo un anno di apprendimento
il comportamento che esibiranno sarà
ancora tranquillo per l'utente
poi prendi privacy perché abbiamo detto
conoscono tutto di noi i problemi anche
di trasferimento psicologico di transfer
per che saranno costruiti per essere
simpatici per essere seduttivi per
essere sexy e quindi è chiaro che io nei
negozi comprerò quello che sarà più sexy
e quindi problemi di innamoramento non
del robot nei confronti dell'essere
umano ma dell'essere umano nei confronti
del robot e quindi abbiamo davvero
un'infinità di problemi di nuove leggi
per gestire le responsabilità se il
fango ashton danno e poi la sicurezza
informatica
pensate che sia un pericolo un lager che
entra il vostro computer vi danneggia il
computer o vi rubano i dati della passio
bene se un hacker prende il controllo
del vostro robot può fare qualunque cosa
può uccidere o può semplicemente
portarvi via gioielli
tutto questo è l'oggetto appunto della
roboetica che non è l'etica attenzione
dei robot perché i robot sono macchine e
l'etica degli esseri umani che usano i
robot quindi arrivato a questo punto voi
pensa potete pensare che il viaggio sia
finito e che quindi il futuro che ci
aspetta è quella appunto di questi
umanoidi che come si vede nel film di
fantascienza si sostituiranno a noi
perché vorranno diventare esseri umani
evolveranno il la creatura che si
ribella al creatore come ci fa vedere la
fantascienza più o meno da sempre vedete
metropolis e del 1921 il primo robot
cinematografico bene in realtà come
diceva un mio professore
il problema è più complesso e forse
anche diverso questo atteggiamento
l'ho battezzato sindrome di pinocchio
questo era un burattino di legno che
voleva diventare un
che è diventato un bambino un robottino
di fatto perché un robot di legno
filoguidato bene è una favola
il robot che diventa un essere umano è
una favola è una proiezione della nostra
favola eterna del nostro figlio che si
ribella al padre in realtà come dicevo
la realtà è più complessa perché qui
stiamo parlando di robot sempre
collegati ad internet per fare cosa cose
semplici abbiamo detto scaricarle
release del software sia ma in realtà i
robot sono pieni di calcolatori non
necessariamente solo non pensate vedete
una macchina c'è il cervello non è così
robinson non sono fatti così non hanno
un cervello hanno tanti cervelli
tutti questi calcolatori sono in rete
quindi è il tipico scenario da calcolo
parallelo anche il vostro cellulare
ormai prima aveva un chip
adesso poi è diventato dual core quad
core acta coro ormai con 200 euro
comprata al telefonino che c'è dentro
otto computer paralleli che accelerano i
processi si dividono il lavoro quindi è
uno scenario di calcolo parallelo tutti
questi robot vivono in una realtà di
telepatia informatica condividono
informazioni condividono strategie
questo qui che vedete è un esempio e un
demo fatto dall'inter non sentite la
musica ma comunque era una squadra in
100 droni che volavano sincronizzati a
disegnare uno spettacolo di luci nel
cielo ma possono fare di più perché
questo scenario di calcolo parallelo è
prodromico alla possibilità di
sviluppare forme di intelligenza
collettiva forma intelligenza connettiva
significa che a questo punto voi potete
immaginare che il robot che avete
davanti
non sarà finito lì non sarà come un
essere umano che ha davanti un individuo
ma sarà un elemento di una squadra di
robot oppure addirittura una specie di
cellule di un organismo robotico che vi
avvolge del quale voi non sapete nemmeno
quali sono i confini come oggi non
sapete
internet e sui calcolatori che cavi che
reti che serve di considerare ecco
quindi uno scenario in cui vivremo
dentro questo schema questa questo eco
sistema robotico che sarà importante
cercare di comprendere
ho iniziato con un libro lasciatemi
finire con un altro libro
questo è un antologia di fred bolaro nel
più famoso autore di racconti di
fantascienza brevi si intitola la
risposta ed è del 1954 appena all
ingegnere a capo di e del via
gli occhi di decine di video camere si
fissarono su di lui e le onde subite
ricche trasmisero da un angolo all'altro
dell'universo le immagini
dell'avvenimento allora con fare solenne
si avvicina alla leva che avrebbe
collegato in un colpo solo tutti i
calcolatori di tutti i pianeti abitati
dell'universo formando un'unica macchina
cibernetica contenente tutto il sapere
di tutte le galassie
il presidente rivolse un breve discorso
agli innumerevoli miliardi di spettatori
poi disse l'ingegnere tutto è pronto
proceda pure questi dopo un attimo di
esitazione abbassa la leva finalmente
tutti i computer i di 96 miliardi di
pianeti erano collegati fra di loro
gli ingegneri fece un passo indietro e
trash un profondo respiro l'onore di
porre la prima domanda spetta a lei
presidente grazie rispose lui rivolte al
pubblico sarà una domanda a cui nessuna
macchina cibernetica mai saputo
rispondere si volta verso lo schermo c'è
dio li mensa voce rispose senza
esitazioni sì adesso dio c'è
il terrore sconvolse la faccia
dell'ingegnere che si slancia verso il
quadro di comando ma un fulmine sceso
dal cielo senza nubi lo in ceneri e fuse
la leva bloccandola per sempre al suo
posto